now it's time for us to look very
closely yeah the three problems that are
at the very heart of fear and trembling
which is turning on the philosophical
floodlights or opening up the sluice
gates of you if you like and really
tackling both photonic or socratic and
attitudes towards faith what he's saying
it actually has a lot of meaning not
just for engaging those philosophical
positions for traditions or schools but
we're philosophy in general is why is
interested philosophy and the very first
one that he begins with the very first
question or the problem is there in a
teleological suspension you notice
there's already some some terminology
there Tilly along they lodged with me
when we have this term we mean things
that are oriented towards a sort of the
anima sometimes is called or purposes
the teleology something is its reason
and this goes back to preterm penalties
and purpose function or something
and is there actually a logical
suspension of the ethical yeah what does
it mean that a suspension in there can
it be put out of play can the ethical
and what the ethical requires the sort
of bracketed or set aside for a case
issue or person for some reason for some
higher purpose this is a possible Bank
effect and he begins by looking at
ladies with understanding philosophy in
which that's not really possible he says
the ethical as such as the universal and
as the universal applies to everyone
that's what it means to be universalism
but but from another angle means that it
applies at all times it rests imminent
and instead has nothing outside of
itself and as its tell us so the ethical
sphere will get exactly what it means
the ethical sphere has its own purpose
within self so a very basic level if
you're going to ask somebody something
like well why what we do things that are
right why what we do things that are
good there's a certain level of
intelligibility that gets lost and even
posing those questions maybe you don't
understand what good means you don't
understand what right actually means or
even feels like you're asking that sort
of question because well you know think
about cases where people do that is it
is the right to do the right thing that
sounds like a tautology right where
somebody's just
Wow sometimes people will say no it's
it's doing the right thing what people
think is the right thing would actually
be the wrong thing in this case because
it would bring up that bad consequences
for it would be in applicable in this
case or you would actually encourage
some bad examples you can think whatever
the sort of thing you want if you're
saying something like that what you're
saying is this looks like the right
thing but it's not really the right
thing because there is a more right
thing which Trump's it which is the
purpose towards which we have the time
so there's that's tell me a larger
problem in that case you've not actually
suspending the ethical you're actually
just expanding it from within so he says
the ethical has nothing outside of
itself and is its Telos itself is the
Tallis for everything outside it's all
the ethical is absorb this into and so
on it goes not further you can unfold
and unpack and develop the atmosphere of
the ethical from within it but there's
nothing outside of it that has to do the
purposes or reasons or goods because
absolute purposes or reasons for goods
walk oriented to the ethical right
isn't that what ethics is about so
that's what Kierkegaard is taking as a
starting point
what about individuals in this case it
says as soon as the individual asserts
himself and his singularity before the
universally since and only by
acknowledging this Canadian again be
reconciled with the universal
every time he the single individual
after having entered the universal feels
an impulse to assert himself as a single
individual he's in a spiritual trial
he's undergoing has played to an
individual and the universal origin the
aesthetic curator to speaks at several
you know places of these different
stages aesthetic stage would want us to
his own desires its own passions one's
own goods that over the whole that of
society that humanity of general
rational creatures together pick
whatever way that you want understand
even just the family universal as
opposed to the individual so if you have
this conception of the ethical as being
valuable then the individual anytime
that he or she sets himself apart from
an opposition he's doing a lot of thing
he's sitting he's engaging and he his
father in so far everything has that
that person that individual was tempted
that person isn't what would a
Kierkegaard calls a spiritual trial
whether it's sort of an interplay
between those movies that's a question
which way are you going to go are you
going to do when you know right or are
you going to do what feels good to you
and here you can say classic clash that
occurs will over and over and over again
between different motives when we do
know that we have designers that are not
fitting into this
yes is to desire some of us to hurt
other people
children what most of them at least
experience that sort of thing we feel
desires to compete with each other or
attention or dominance or all sorts of
things whether we deserve it or not we
feel envious towards other people there
are many different things you can think
of we want to have things for ourselves
even if it means taking them away from
other people these places in opposition
to what he's the ethical person so he
says how can you get out of a spirit of
trial you've been working with yourself
out of it by unrepentantly surrendering
as a single individual the universe
repentantly that's a very important term
there it's not enough just to do it one
has to actually change one's mind set he
says this is the highest that can be
said of me on today's existence and the
ethical is of the same nature as a
person's eternal salvation which is his
tell us forever worn at all times the
highest debt that we didn't conceive of
the best the visit to put this in terms
what is the happiness for human beings
what is the ultimate good
doesn't lie then within the realm of the
says it would be a contradiction for
this to be capable of being surrendered
that is logically suspended because as
soon as this is suspended its
relinquished whereas damage is suspended
as not relinquished the preservative the
higher which is Astellas so if there's
the purpose of human life that's the
purpose of a human being
ultimately lies within this reality the
realm which can be understood Universal
which applies to everything which
encompasses everything which is
intelligible which can be made clear
there's nothing and nothing could
suspend us but this is possible could
there was he says what about think what
about Avery if you think about the
nature of what Abraham was doing you
know if if you look at it in purely
ethical terms the way that being invited
like it says the name for when Abraham
was doing his murderer he's trying to
kill his son Gavin to God told him to
assure that God is telling him to do
something that is murdered so that makes
not Abraham probable that makes God if
we judge it on the basis
in part because God is not telling him
to do this for any reason he's not
saying kill your son because that's
going to produced the greatest benefit
from the greatest amount of people his
sacrifice
he's not doing anything business day
this is a way in which reasonable work
itself out of history and producing
paradise or anything like that this will
actually cement the bond in our group
God is not saying anything it doesn't
give Avery have a reason to do it you
just tell something doing so here we get
to fate
Kierkegaard says faith is this paradox
that the single individual is higher
than the universal so we don't need a
vigil to the universal and then beyond
it once again to the individual this is
the stage of the religious or faith this
is something that provide a higher tell
us a higher purpose a higher good at
higher reason which then supersedes the
ethical at least in that case he says
the faith is this paradox the single
individual is higher than the universal
yeah please note in such a way that the
movement repeats itself so that they
have after having been in the universal
he is the single individual isolates
himself as higher than the universal if
this is not faith he says that Abraham
has lost and faith has never existed in
this world because it's always existed
for the ethical social morality is the
highest and there isn't a person no
residual income
in commence rebuilding it can't be
boiled down can't be translated can't be
fit back into the ethanol there's a line
that can't be crossed the aesthetic the
individual can in fact be assimilated
into the other part but here you reach
the point where there's there's an
overflow of surplus that cannot be
assimilated back to the system social
morality for finding ethical the highest
is the highest and if there isn't a
person no residual intranets durability
in some way that this influencer ability
is not evil another way that things can
be in conventional is through through
evil the system that doesn't me actually
admit that it roots adult that doesn't
mean the evil doesn't continue to exist
in the world as other people don't do
bad things and even when they don't you
think sometimes they're tempted to do
bad things there's an inner commencer
ability there this is a
incommensurability that lets you look at
that and say that's wrong that's evil
you know they're people who do murder
and they're condemned by the you know
unless there's some sort of purposes of
this the indictment now i said something
else very interesting if that's the case
we don't have something like this then
all we need is read philosophy the
categories that read philosophy and are
sufficient to incorporate individuals or
at least allow us to figure out what the
heck is going on with people who do the
right thing and arise from being at the
level of
the level of the ethical people who
remain it it allows us to make sense
Greek philosophy to be though the freak
philosophy is not says this is a very
interesting place people who are
profoundly lacking learning how to do
new cliches are frequently heard to say
a light shines over the Christian world
whereas the darkness and trans paganism
this is always directed a stranger every
more thorough thinner every more earnest
artist still regenerates himself eternal
youth of the Greeks the Greeks have a
ton of walk with us don't they it's
quite right to say that thinkin ISM
didn't have faith but if something is
supposed to have been sent there by one
must have clear interested able take
this so what is faith so the faith is
precisely the paradox that the single
individual as the single individual is
higher than a diversity this justified
before not as it inferior as when you
know here but as superior yet in such a
way that is the single individual who
after being subordinate to as a single
individual to the universal now means in
the universal becomes a single
individual who is it so you have to
actually passed through the ethical on
the way can't just jump from here to
here we'll talk about that a little more
later so he says it's certainly true the
single individual and easily confused as
paradoxes spiritual trials sort of thing
that's half
down here that's happening here but it
ought not to be concealed for that
reason that's certainly true that many
people may be so constituted that
they're repulsed by them I know many
people who was you talk about this sort
of thing with that thing it drives them
nuts they say no faith is just purely
subjective it's down here as individuals
private has to be taken up to the
University but faith would not therefore
be made into something else to be able
when they have it well one watch hadn't
been tonight heavily well those who have
faith he says want to be prepared to set
forth some characteristics we're by the
paradigm what's taking place up here is
different than the spiritual trial so
this is a good place to stop and and
that you're reading through this test
he's going to use these terms over and
over again
Tara Knox spiritual trial paradox
spiritual try spiritual trial is what is
occurring when the individual is
struggling as individual with the realm
of the ethical the paradox is what is
occurring when the individual is
actually sort of a superseded
so this one we have to carry knives this
level we have spiritual how are these
fundamentally different well again let's
go back to the story of Abraham Abraham
was told by God your sacrifice Isaac
would you do it in this way
and Abraham lost God's what abraham
actually goes and prepares to do it so
the story of abraham contains just such
a teleological suspension of the ethical
all sorts of people try to interpret it
and make it into the allegories for this
event and draw analogies but Kierkegaard
says if one looks more closely I doubt
very much that anyone in the whole wide
world will find one single analogy
except for a later one which proves
nothing if it is certain that Abraham
represents faith in ethical terms
Abraham's relation Isaac is quite simply
this and what it was an ethics teach us
about fathers and sons the father shall
love the son more than himself within
its own confines the ethical has various
gradations it's not the state of being
ethical is there's one single thing
there's different levels that are
possible to proceed through and you're
always lining up within the doings so if
you say well what if the what if you
have a conflict between a son and a
mother one of them has to be sacrificed
to save the life the other that's still
over the realm of the other there's a
higher reason why I was doing not just
sacrificing a person just for the house
of fun
what he says when an enterprising
concern to a whole nation is impeded
when such a project is halted by
dividing the planet with displeasure
when the soothsayer carries on the stand
task announces that the deity and that
demands a young girl the sacrifice and
the father was 408 with a greater
sacrifice fathers merciful so long their
daughters were themselves but for the
good of the whole good of the society
sometimes people have to be sacrificed
and we actually do have several cases
where this takes place you think about
not just you know Greek tragedy with a
Tibetan on if a junior there's also the
story of Jeff his own daughter he vowed
to sacrifice the first who came out of
his house of God to grant Israel victory
and God does the first person to come
out of his house first thing to come out
of his house his daughter he also talks
about Brutus
the state of wrong so he says but in the
crucial moment Agamemnon Jeff that
Brutus heroically overcome the agony and
we have lost the beloved and have only
to complete the task externally there
will never be a noble soul in the world
without tears of compassion for their
agony we can relate to that we can
understand that the admiration for their
deed but if at the crucial moment these
three men were to appended the raw
courage with which they bore the agony
the little phrase what's going on it
says who would understand them if they
went on to explain this we believe by
virtue of the absurd who would
understand them any better so what's the
difference between the traffic here oh
yeah
Avery traffic here remains the tragic
hero is understandable he allows the
expression of the ethical tannins
television a higher expression of the
ethical so he sacrifices something which
is a good for a greater good
all that lies not doing it never had to
drink something with different
since Abraham situation is different
Biden's acted transgress the ethical
altogether and have a higher tallest
outside of it in relation to which he's
suspended what was that higher tells
Abraham blogged and trusted in God and
believed by virtue of the observed
against the ethical and there wasn't any
sort of well this is all for the better
you know for society there was just
you're gonna do this he was still able
to believe that God good so he says here
the category of a necessity of a new
category to the understanding of Abraham
becomes apparent paganism does not know
such a relationship to the divine the
tragic hero does not enter into any
private relationship with the divine but
the ethical is the so this is the
relationship between God and the
individual you would I've just got
mediated through the society priesthood
or through kingship or through you know
any sort of Enlightenment idea like the
kingdom of ends or humanity and such a
universal thing it's God in relationship
with concrete human beings says Abraham
cannot be mediated in other words he
cannot speak as soon as I speak I
express the universal and if I do not do
so no one can understand me as soon as
the Abraham wants to Express
he's stuck with this he stuck with
making sense other things in terms of
you know what's better for everybody
else was better for society what you
know concha and ethics would say
utilitarian ethics of course the Abraham
doesn't know these but he suppose for
the ones so he says therefore although
Ibrahim arouses my admiration he also
appalled me the person who denies
himself and sacrifices himself because
of Duty gives up the finite in order to
grasp the Internet is adequately assured
we talked about this before with the
idea of the night of faith and hero the
resignation infinite resignation means
being ok with some casted up one's
desires
passing death perhaps even one's own
loved ones oh I'm good for the sake of
some other and it doesn't necessarily
have to be the whole of society it could
be something with giving somebody else
your spot on the lifeboat or sacrificing
your own time life labor energy to
better
their children love that would be
expression of the ethical Kierkegaard
that resignation Abraham doesn't do this
Abraham goes beyond that he says how
does the single individual reassure
himself it is legitimate it's a simple
man to level all existence to the idea
that state Indian society if you do that
it's really easy to mediate and you
never come to the paradox but the single
individual matters more the dad is
exactly what Abraham is doing so that
gets us through the first of these promo
now let's look at the second so the
second problem that's posed and
trembling
is there an absolute duty to God in the
heaven these minutes today the only
absolute disc
the absolute is understood by the
ancient Greeks and also by contemporary
philosophy of particular time and also
by you know they like minted many others
a philosophical viewpoint to woods the
the absolute is lying in the realm of
the universal over the ethical it's the
highest that it can read and it sort of
brings religion into that you know
what's good at religion which sort of
sucked
mirror a lot of that put that into the
the ethical Taran is asserting that
there's something above that so he says
the ethical is a universal and as such
it's the divine
so it's proper to say that every duty is
essentially duty to God but if no more
can be said than this that's also so
that I actually have no duty towards God
so this is one conception that people
have the duty becomes duty by being
trace back to God so God is the origin
of why I want to do this or thing but in
the duty itself I did not venture into a
relation with God it's very different to
have a metaphysical principle that
you're trying to live in accordance with
and to live in accordance with the call
the command the cajoling the wishes of
the person of something else right so he
says for instance it's a duty to love
ones neighbor and some duty but being
traced back to God but in the duty I
entered into a relation not to God but
there's a neighbor and you can
secularize this with the thing gerdes
right
it's something God where God is a tree
or God as you know you haven't even
large your God as being nice to each
other
pick whatever you like right we could
use any of those nice
he says if in this connection then stay
it's my duty to look out I'm actually
pronouncing a tautology and as much as
God and a totally abstract sense is here
understood visited by its are like you
have a duty to attend to tease you ought
to love loving well what is it the more
robust conception of God if you don't
look at God I says insofar as one might
wish to love God in another way this
love would be as implausible as a lot of
were so Allah mentions whereby a person
was the cat ears and so the woman is his
neighborhood hope it was variable track
what if you actually love the God of
Abraham Jacob
he says the answer computer it's a task
for the single individual down here to
stripped himself of the qualification of
interior order to make things external
to make them out here for other people
to see if you love somebody you have to
express them otherwise the law itself
doesn't exist if you're justified you
have to show that justification
otherwise it doesn't exist he says every
time the end of the individual strokes
River that region to me withholds
himself or slips slips down to the
qualifications of feeling mood etc that
belong to tier II already he trespasses
he
there's a burst of spiritual trial the
paradox of faith is that there's an
interior already on this hundred that is
in commence herbal with exterior and
then engineer interior already that is
not identical to the first in a new
interior so at the level of the ethical
everything can be made clear everything
can be xperia
can be made external there's something
to a person that cannot be fully
expressed and it's not just a purely
subjective the isolated individual
though here opposed to the ethical is
rather than they're connected with God
and the appellation itself cannot be
fully cognitive that cannot be fully
explained before the character so he
says the paradox of faith is that this
that the single individuals higher than
the universal that the single individual
determines his relation to the universal
to the other by in relation to the
absolute now this relation to the
absolute bias relation to the universal
the paradox may be expressed in this way
that there is an absolute duty to God
for this relationship of duty the
individual relates himself as a single
individual absolutely to the absolute so
what does the do here duty the duty is
to God but the duty is also to to love
them to align oneself so he says now
here's here's a very important point
that often gets lost over time character
guard is being presented so he says from
this it does not follow that the ethical
should
a lot of people want to read
Kierkegaard's especially with their big
philosophy religion classes as if you'd
say well you need out we've got the
individual and then you've got an
ethical this whole realm you know
everything can be understood if it makes
sense
philosophy fits in there and then is
leap into the divine and God could tell
you to do anything whatsoever and that
totally destroyed us this if we accept
this but that means that anything goes
all bets are off if God wants us all
with it become murderers tomorrow and it
tells us to do that we should all try to
be like Abraham doesn't want to stop our
hands that behave okay that is not about
what you're saying he's saying the
ethical should not be invalidated rather
the ethical receives a completely
different expression of paradoxical
expressions such as for example that
love to God they bring the night of
faith to give love to his neighbor think
about how many people now this is going
to serve a reflection on our fallenness
brokenness and our logical condition
think about how many people who live a
life in which they say they have some
sort of faith relationship treat other
people well even when they don't feel
like it and not they say that they're
not able to do it just by swim you know
looking at it they're not people are
doing in essence when the person who's
experienced try about this level does if
they succeeded
instead they say God helped me through
God actually gave me the strength to to
love these other people and to not hate
them like I tend to do if that's real if
that's the case that would be with
materials talking about the ethical
itself becomes sort of penetrated
translated by the paradoxical by the
divine he says this is not the case that
fate has no place in existence then
faith is just a spiritual product people
who think that they're in faith but
really just down here and then get
thrown over for key feelings and desires
and they're projecting this this notion
of God or something but if God really
exists that's more like this now notice
to it it's possible that a person could
actually talk the talk of faith and even
to a certain extent walk through the
water but still be down here and he had
a spiritual trial because really it's
really about themselves
an idea that they have and I'm sure a
projection of your own desires who
wishes and not they sort of openness a
receptiveness a willingness to to trust
to go and to commit so he says the
paradox the students the single
individual wants to express is the
absolute duty individual becomes
conscious of it in the universal he
recognizes he's involved in a spiritual
trial and if it really does resistant
does not resistant than have any sense
that's what spiritual trial is what's
going on with faith faith involves
something coming from without something
surplus something greater something that
needs it not just being individual by
itself Kierkegaard also said something
else very interesting sort of a sign
here can the paradox of the faith - if
he sort of shared or communicated could
be maybe not necessarily Terminator 2
attacks part merciful but could it be
passed on to your spiritual this is one
here's one place where I act myself I
would actually differently let's see
what he actually synthesis people fancy
that the single individual can make
himself understandable to another single
individual in the same situation
partnership that means areas of offices
it's utterly unthinkable only the single
individual in ever given us all the more
explicit explanation of what is to be
understood by Isaac what it is it they
are supposed to sacrifice what it is
that they are suppose to do what he sees
there is the danger of people sort of
trying to holy hangout to each other's
coattails and thereby ride themselves
into the paradox of the passion faith he
talks about people hoping to smuggle
Christianity into instead what's
required is actually to two things
courage and love and he talks about
himself as actually lacking the courage
to do this but as
understanding and recognizing that
courage of others and he says the words
of terror meaning this explanation of
thing but I dare say they can be
understood without the necessary
consequence that one who has understood
them as the courage to do what he has
understood what ought to be sufficiently
honest to admit what it says to admit
that it is greater than the one insult
lacks the courage to do it honest dezik
must be honest he must be and he must
not speak of this lack of courage as
humility since on the contrary it's
actually tried to not trust to remain at
this level is in a way it was what
you're going to remain in a kind of
human pride as opposed to truth and
melody which lies at this level
he says the courage of faith is the one
and only true humble courage then it
talked about love he says it's easy to
see that if this passage is to have any
meaning it must be understood literally
passage and also passage about lose say
that's the trouble with memory saying if
you want to if anyone comes to me and
does not hate his own father and mother
wife and children brothers and sisters
even his own life he cannot be my
disciple God Daisy says is the Wonder to
be an absolute love so the absolute duty
is to love God not just half way not
just lukewarm 'only to love God is to
you know if you actually understand God
as being God God is infinitely lovable
so the absolute duty to love God is not
you know something too
that way or order the way 3/4 of the way
it's the fulfill absolutely he says
anyone who in demanding a person's long
believes as well as demonstrated by
these become different to what he
otherwise cherish is not merely an
egotist but it's also stupid
what is commanded here is a wrongheaded
conception of what it means to love God
absolutely does the love of God
absolutely be in saying everything else
is garbage nothing compares everything
else is just doesn't get Curtis verb and
pick whatever you want it's not safe
like he says just as we think about
human beings
the man requires his wife to be their
father and mother but if he can if he
considers it a demonstration of an
extraordinary lover and that she for a
state became indifferent life's water
he's far more stupid than the stupid if
the a me and him mother look is he would
wish to discover that she was perfect in
her wasn't a hard system and he was seen
there in this you loved him more than
anyone thank you
so again to witness
into perspective abraham who loves isaac
it's his son it's what he's been waiting
for all this it's the product of Kim and
Sarah and also God he loves it's no
sacrifice to give up something that you
don't love and being told you have to do
this because you love me if to get
around that you find a way to make
yourself no longer love the things that
you have to sacrifice that's not doing
what Cuba card is talking about or what
God demands when he said that we are
going ice axes were asked to give up
we're not supposed to stop mother the
Isaac when we do that
he says the absolute duty can lead one
to do and ethics would forbid but it can
never leave the night of faith to stop
love it so now let's let's move on a
little bit before it's still talking
about the distress and anxiety of the
fear and trembling of the paradox of
faith and again it comes back to this is
this contrast between the tragic hero at
the level of the ethical and the 950 the
tragic hero relinquishes himself in
order to express the universal the night
of faith languishing
the universal so Abraham actually says
yeah this is murder
I'm not supposed to murder I'm not
supposed to lay I'm not even supposed to
attend in the market to my son yet God
what I love is they ask this of me and I
do love myself I'm fulfilling the duties
yet God is asking so I'm going to love
God more trust with him that's what the
the tragedy the night of faith is giving
he's not just giving up some individual
desire that allows himself to forego
some love on his part that he designs
himself to losing he's not sacrificing
one thing to be good in society he is
actually sacrificing this he's allowing
himself to be come on balance with the
ethical that he knows does of my
goodness for the stake of the higher
business that he also arms in his proper
place so he says that said previously
everything depends on one to the ones
position anyone who believes is fairly
easy to do the single individual and
I'll always be sure he's not the knight
of faith for fly-by-nights and enter of
geniuses or not of faith on the contrary
this make knows it was glorious to
belong in Universal Agamemnon was a
great man Jeff that's a great man we
could go down the list Socrates is great
he knows it is beautiful and beneficial
maybe the single individual translates
himself into the universal the one if so
speak personally produces a trim clean
as far as possible
faultless addition of himself readable
all Socrates is probably the one who
comes the closest to dismiss you don't
think about the credo with the fader and
all these other places where he's
expressing why he's willing to die for
the sake of being capped by the
appellants for the sake of the truth he
said you know was that that is
refreshing to become understandable to
himself with Universal in such a way
that he understands it and every
individual understands him in turn
understand as the universal in him both
rejoices and security to universal
that's not available for the night that
capacity to rest in intelligibility and
universality and knowledge that this is
in fact the right thing again he talks
about courageous of the manifests knows
that it is inspiring to give himself up
with universal and it takes courage to
do it but that there is also security
and precisely because it is giving up
for the universal he knows this glorious
to be understood by everyone noble mind
and yet at the same time there's
something higher college so he says
whether the single individual is
actually some you're going to experience
a trial or as native faith only the
single individual
get aside and again this is where we
might differ from curative care a little
bit he is saying no sort of guidebook
for this is possible no discernment of
souls as it was called earlier Christian
traditions is is possible to do but we
do have to do at least grant in this
these once we get to this level we start
to talk about things that by their very
nature are extremely difficult to pin
down and to talk about not just because
their mysteries the absolutely but
because they actually take place through
ordinary things which are invested with
much greater meaning so one has to you
know look to see what the criterion is
that cap the night of faith actually
passed through the ethical on to the
religious or were they try to make a
jump from here to here in that case
they're just a spiritual trial and all
that's going on is is sort of
oscillation between the ethical and the
aesthetic and if Abraham was doing that
Abraham is really evil demon demon but
he doesn't think that that's the case
for Avery
Abraham's case it's this so that is
problem - is there an absolute duty to
God
yes there is this is what it looks like
this is how it takes shape it doesn't
invalidate or nullify the realm of the
ethical as a matter of fact loves it
even so it actually acknowledges it yeah
it says yes this is all good but there
is something yet higher than we have to
and that permeates the realm of the
ethical so you might say it's not be for
somebody like Kierkegaard it's not
possible to fully grasp this realm
perfect intelligibility all the way
through to grasp its own goodness
without the languages irritated apana
and through it it permeates it from the
religious now with the look at problem
three so we're coming to a close now
with the problem of three it was an
ethical was an ethically defensible for
Abraham to conceal this understanding
and who did he concealed it from from
Sarah
familiy aids that are the promisor so
very interesting way of ghastliness you
know it's not just did Abraham conceal
as understanding from Joe Blow monastry
or anybody else wasn't ethically
defensible for him to conceal his
understanding of what was going on from
those to whom he was
like it's their lives and we loved a
good question and before we actually
jump into that I want to read you to two
passages and they want to make sort of
remark about this this section one of
the passages is very short so there it
is at first he says this is a note
closed when he's talking about a family
says ethics is a dangerous branch of
knowledge and it was surely possible to
hear a stoppage for purely ethical
reasons decided to look after pass
judgment on the perverse age
Aristophanes was well known for his form
of comedy in which which laughter was
actually used to pass judgment ethics is
a dangerous branch of knowledge when you
actually move into the ethical it's not
just all white and hair and sweetness
and strings playing or anything like
that
it forces tough choices
- really - really the line one song but
the ethical means 21 itself inside out
ripping off one's heart sacrificing
things that one would ordinarily want
that's what it means to truly be in the
realm of the ethical that's what tragic
heroes actually do those who fitted the
other thing another passage that I want
to hit on has to do with sin and he says
here I would like to make a comment that
says more than it has been said any
point free music so Cary Grant says that
I think that's look
sin is not the first immediacy so it's
been talked about as if well we've met
the individual level level of the
aesthetic and the universal ethical in
so far as the individual is out of line
with the ethical follows his own desires
has wishes that are contrary to the
ethical order here she says is that sin
is not the first immediacy simulator in
music in sin the single individual is
already higher than the universal so
interesting when you're having a
spiritual trial or the individual has
made him or herself higher than
universal this is actually a possibility
now they actually higher the universal
than sense that they belong there but
that is actually a possibility so he
says the single individuals higher in
the direction of the demonic paradise
because it is a contradiction on the
part of the universal to want to demand
itself from a person who lacks the
condensed EOC nakatome for it there's a
there's a contradiction between the
ethical demanding of people who can't
give to the ethical what the ethical
that's demanding from them
for the ethical to be demanding them so
the certain way the ethical is on the
inside here he's saying that the goal is
demanding more than it walked more than
it has a right to and so you know this
is very platonic sort of point you know
he is the ethical itself he says if with
other things philosophy were also able
we're also to think that it might just
enter a man's head to want to act
according to its teaching we would get a
strange again a comedy on an ethics that
ignores sin is a completely futile
discipline but as a affirms that as a
lips I've exceeded itself
very interesting point here what he's
talking about here are the possibilities
for philosophy too you might say get
beyond its own limits you might turn it
into something other than philosophy of
the process but this is a possibility
for philosophy if philosophy does not
take skin seriously then if there's
something wrong with it it's blackness
there's a superficiality to it and
partly the fact of sin is that the
individual can stand against thee if
philosophy does takes it seriously then
suddenly it has to start opening itself
up to that which goes beyond religious
so this is a very important and very
interesting point one that's might say
pregnant
that fully developed philosophy teaches
that the immediate should be unhealthy
says that's true enough but what is not
true is that sin is directly the
immediate any more than that faith is
directly sinned and faith in some way
it's flip sides of the same coin I'm not
saying that they're identical or that
sin becomes faith or anything like that
but within Kierkegaard's character God's
understanding of philosophy and faith
unless we actually take a count off the
meaning of sin it becomes impossible to
fully understand this so those are the
remarks that I wanted to get what is
going on in this he's telling a lot more
stories in this one than he has been in
any of the other words
yeah he's reiterating a lot of points
that he's made already so I'm going to
skip over them I'm going to try to hit
on what's what's actually doing this he
says it would be best at this point to
consider the whole question purely
aesthetically and to that end and enter
an aesthetic and inquiry to which I
invite the reader to give his entire
attention momentarily so now who's
opening up is this model the and it
talks about the category of the
interesting okay so the interesting is a
boarder category between aesthetics and
ethics accordingly this examination was
constantly water into the territory of
ethics so what's going on there I'm
going to skip over some of these these
issues what about the case of
and to actually Agamemnon about to
sacrifice if a geniu aesthetics to ban
silence of the Academical him as much as
it would be unworthy of the here to see
comfort from any other persons at that
level where he's being depicted we sort
of leave him to himself and there is an
interior origin but what is the statics
do it finds other ways to open the
software to to us he says in order to be
a hero the hero has to be tried it's
dreadful spiritual trial what does the
spin of student is we have it as an old
servant disclose their agra things in
order but alex has no coincidence and
don't want cervantes disposal
aesthetic and yet contradicts itself as
soon as it's two people that didn't
actually for this reason ethics demands
disclosure to be ethical to be in the
realm of the ethical character means
being able to explain yourself even if
that not just the action but the
explanation turns you inside out maybe
even wrecks you he talks about the
tragic hero who says the tragic hero
demonstrates his ethical courage and
that he himself now create an aesthetic
illusion
now just announces if a genius painter
if it does that the tragic hero is
ethics beloved sign of movement is well
pleased if you remain silent maybe
because he believes it make
for others but it may also because it
makes it easier for himself because her
relative requires current part of this
courage is that it is not and he goes on
with other examples like this yeah he
also brings up the category the
aesthetic which which ends up being the
demon attic and one of the possibilities
for us is and some of the settings of
the religious to sort of say to the
ethical no I'm not going to do it I will
stand against you and why does he call
this the demon I thought you know what
do you think about what it was that was
the original said human original stated
that further back what was it was it was
pride he was saying I will not I would
be when I am and I will not have
somebody else overly even the the
ethical and I can take different shapes
and Kierkegaard is very attuned to how
easily this may seem to some people like
the stage of their religious but there
is welders desire while there's passion
there is not actually any true love he
talks about well
passage starting with the Richard the
third that great example with demonite
character he says nature's such as those
are basically at the paradox and they're
by no means more imperfect than other
people except that they are either lost
in the demon the demon demonic paradox
often because of pain often because they
rejected and Richard the third he's
invited to sort of lose himself in the
realm of the ethical he's always going
to be the person down if he does that
they are neither lots of the demonic
paradox were saved in the divine
paradise time and time again people have
been pleased that witches missus trolls
or malformed creatures and no doubt
everyone has an inclination when he sees
a malformed person to attach them and
give a little cravat what a glaring
injustice since the relation will not to
be turned around the existence itself
has damaged he says just as a stepmother
makes the children traverse the demonic
for which the individual himself has no
guilt has its beginning it is originally
being set outside of the universal by
nature or historical situation so this
is not the same thing he has the realm
of religious no this is not what is
going on with a breeder let me go on
denier and this is where we're going to
get to to come to a close he says how
did he act I have not forgotten the
reader but please remember I got
involved the previous discussion
obstacle now does it Abraham could
thereby become more comprehensible but
in order that the in comprehensibility
to become more salient because they said
before I cannot understand any Breanna I
can only admire him Abraham did not
speak he did not speak to Sarah or
Eliezer Isaac he bypassed these three
ethical authorities from some sir
Abraham the ethical had no higher
discretion than family life the statics
allowed even demanded silence of that
single individual if he knew by
remaining silent you could save another
this will only show us it is not within
the realm of aesthetics either because
silence is not in order to save Isaac in
fact his whole task of sacrificing Isaac
for his own and for God's sake is it
affects to aesthetics because it was
able understand I've sacrificed myself
enough that I sacrificed someone else
for my own sake meanwhile ethics pass
judgment on him because he was silent on
account of his individual accidental
particularity Abraham cannot speak he
says because he cannot stay that much
would explain everything that is so it
is understandable that it is an ordeal
such that what does the temptation
temptation is not to give in to the
individual it's better sometimes
sometimes not all times
sometimes characters say God I've come
to the end of us that we go beyond what
it is that human beings and philosophy
and naturally even reason working itself
out and society have given to us
reliable guides most of the time as
knowledge of good and evil sometimes we
actually have to go beyond that yeah
trust
got express love for God by making that
choice making that commitment she would
say so the ends up saying cheer again
and as a parent one can perhaps
understand Abraham but only the way one
understands the paradox I for my part
perhaps can understand you Graham but I
also realize that do not have the
courage to speak in this way no more
that I have encouraged to act as Abraham
did but by no means so I'd therefore say
to the act is of little importance it
says on the contrary it is that one and
mark that's what I'm going to leave off
with our exposition of spirit trembling
you've seen us go through many different
themes involved in this schema
religiously ethical the aesthetic has
now become quite clear and Abraham as we
can see is something quite different
sort of rupture ya think a pair of
illness and not just any kind of paradox
there are other paradoxes available it's
a perfectly blur stay not everything
that is very actionable is necessarily
faith it has to in fact passed through
the Rasch recognize the rationality and
the goodness of the rational the
universal the ethical before against
assuming or teleologically suspended